all right welcome back Berlin and Angel
Blue
nice to see you guys again
what's going on what's going on with
your in your world since the last time
we spoke anything new
may I speak yes
oh we've been doing quite a bit of
traveling
you guys are always traveling yes and
this weekend it was Easter so that was a
big thing because we did
um Church the whole weekend then we did
a Easter egg hunt so it's been very busy
so you guys go to church
yes you wouldn't I wouldn't think that
that would be part of your life
given the the
Rings called the Baphomet Rings the the
oh church with the giant horns we were
right yeah I know what you're talking
about church is very important because
the way that we want to
um our kids are raised with
God as number one
family number two
so we make sure to have that as the
foundation
for everything that's number one that's
interesting what was the significance of
those rings that you were wearing last
time
those Rings
um they were a spiritual thing I I think
we can leave that as a mystery okay I
think we can leave you have to answer
every question I ask that's right I give
I give people the ability to
say let's move on to the next question
and I accept that and take it
so tell me about your relationship um
I'd love to delve deeper into
what what it's like to be in a Master
Slave
uh relationship is is being the master
something you've kind of always
been into in your relationships or is it
just this relationship that's taken
home it's in this relationship that is
more expressed itself it is it it is
expressed itself more fully
yes
what is your favorite
part of being of being Angel Blue's
Master uh well
in all honesty it's fulfilling my
responsibility
that uh
that is the most fulfilling part of it
for me
there's a lot of responsibility
just as there's a lot of giving
but there's a lot of responsibility
and Angel Blue what would you say is
your favorite
part of being
Berlin's slave
my favorite part is
it I feel it completes me I was complete
before I met him but there's that extra
kick to it and although I had purpose
before I met him he gave me more purpose
and
years years ago
I was somebody that wasn't doing very
well I was hanging out with the wrong
crowd I was sleeping on the streets I
had boyfriends who were criminals who
were doing life sentences right now
and I had to pull myself out of that
which I did that all on my own went to
college started University and I knew
that I wanted to change I knew that I
wanted something better
and um
in doing that it led me to finding
somebody
of value and when I met him
it just came together perfect
and he's helped me a lot
we've um I feel like we've grown
together how many years have you been
together thirty thousand
that's a long time that is
you've had uh you've had ups and downs
as any relationship or
of course
but you you weather them and carry on
yes and quite frankly
uh the nature of our relationship tends
to uh
make it easier to resolve
conflict or issues
it just does
because you guys have this contract that
you mentioned last time because we have
an agreed upon
power relationship
um and uh
blue has her own agency and
she entered into this relationship of
her own agency
but
when a captain has one ship
strike that where the ship has one
captain
um
it's much easier to navigate through
things
blue is always
available to make suggestions to give
input
but in the end I make the decisions
and that's agreed
and that eliminates a lot of
inflict
we talked about this last time but what
what is it that you bring to this
relationship it's guidance of course I
bring guidance
I bring care
I bring structure
um
those are the things I bring
and financial support mainly yes from
you that's
part of my responsibility
I take my responsibilities
very seriously and
I appreciate
having responsibility and fulfilling
that responsibility
what do you bring
to this relationship
I bring
my nature is to please
I like to please the person that I love
and that
helps me in so many ways as Berlin does
help me so I please I obey
I'm obedient to him
and I serve just as Berlin serves me I
serve him too
and there's a lot of creativity between
us when we come together I always feel
as if we're children I always say
burning the house down I always see fire
um because we have so much fun so much
fun even when we're not doing anything
you know just hanging out
it's always gosh it's always fun the
mundane things are fun so
um I would say Joy
there's a lot of Joy well we both bring
that to each other really
well I I I'm considerably more serious
and uh
she helps balance that with a lighter
and more joyful and playful element
this relationship is this a dynamic of a
relationship that you would recommend to
other couples or other people no
I wouldn't recommend anything to other
people
this is simply our experience
and we can eschew the the labels of
Master Slave it's
the dynamic of our relationship
is
what is important and what lies behind
that Dynamic what's expressed through
that dynamic is what's important but
it's up to each individual in each
couple
to to find their way
if what we have to say helps
then
or gives a different alternative and
and makes it available to someone
without stigmatization then
then we've done what we came here to do
by these interviews
and you have children yes you have you
have some children
um we have one uh one child left at home
uh
and um
yes
we do and that of course how does this
Master Slave
relationship
do you do do you show that to your
children or do they not see it
uh
they don't see it
um
we
we don't believe that it's appropriate
to
put our ways on others it's
it's
um
it occurs in everyday life
in front of the children but only in
subtle ways
ways that
are not discernible unless you look for
it may speak yes so
um children
I try to protect kids from knowing any
kind of when we do our fetish in our
hardcore extreme
sexual things everything is done when
there is nobody home just us so none of
that everything's put away everything
they have there's nobody has any idea of
that type of stuff that goes on and
um as far as our daily life in front of
any children because there's sleepovers
and all kinds of things parties so as
far as our daily life we keep everything
the only difference between everybody
else and us would be it's more formal
there's more structure
if I'm going out I do ask Berlin
is it okay if I go to the store right
now is it okay things like that but to
others
to the naked eye it seems just very
formal and
um respect but there's nothing
that would give our
our lifestyle or fetish away there's
nothing that any
any child or even anybody like work wise
or anything like that would know so I
don't want to be too nosy especially
about your sexual life but you you kind
of hinted at something that you guys get
into some
darker yes play we do we we get into a
lot of very dark extreme things
and I feel very lucky because
it's hard to meet somebody that
will accept you in that way and a lot of
people previous to Berlin they were not
accepting me years and years of people
thinking I'm odd I'm weird I can't do
that
um I respect you too much but it had
nothing to do with respect those were my
desires you either share that or you
don't and they didn't which is fine
and so when Berlin and I met I I was the
one who
went deeper and I opened doors I
suggested I never I cannot tell I cannot
tell him what to do like I can only
suggest and that's what I did and he
went he he loved it
he loved it and I felt like At Last
after
you know uh previous people and it was
never working out at last there was
somebody that
that it just um worked with the puzzle
piece fit yes we fit perfectly perfectly
and
you know
Angel Lou used the term respect and and
we've used it before
and it's very important and and really
how could we
how could we really respect each other
anymore
than accepting each other
with
whatever we came to the table with
um
how could I respect her more than saying
yes
fine
there's room for you
this one for all of you
this is your submissive role
Angel Blue ever do you ever feel like
you want to disobey or
you know just not play the role of
submissive partner all the time uh
there's times when I want to disobey
because I'm a human always have been a
little rebellious and
um
in the beginning it was very difficult
when we first got together but we did
when we first met it wasn't a Master
Slave relationship and I was very
um
self-destructive and destructive and I
would sabotage every relationship the
men that came previous to Berlin I
sabotaged every relationship I would
break things uh I I was really into
violence and a lot of people stepped
away what do you think that was all
about
well because I grew up in a violent
household and I equated love with
violence so I would always bring it into
my relationships and it became
unbearable for
my partners for every partner that I had
it became unbearable and
um when I met Berlin it was like that in
the beginning it was extreme he's the
only man that
the patients in Berlin is incredible
because all the others they could not
they didn't know what to do they did not
know what to do and Berlin now I'm
nothing like that now all of that is
gone
um the rebelliousness the sabotaging the
violence the police getting caught there
was police all the time I would I was
acting crazy outside acting crazy inside
I couldn't act like
you know a a normal person and now
Berlin has stabilized you
a lot what is what is your favorite
quality
in Berlin
gosh he's so fierce
he's fiercely loyal he is fiercely loyal
and that to me is the most important
thing in a person because I'm also very
loyal and he's very strong
he is one of the strongest people
if not the strongest that I have ever
met
and his patience he has the patience of
a saint to withstand me he's got the
patience I've estained
and she
is still mischievous
and she can be a brat
yes that's true
huh which makes it fun yes it's it's all
EX within acceptable limits what is your
favorite quality in Angel Blue
um
her loyalty
that's my
that is my favorite quality
for loyalty into her honesty
it's beautiful
what would you guys say is the most
surprising thing
about your relationship
the people that are watching these
videos like
maybe they're making assumptions and
they fill in the blanks of what they
think it's all about but what do you
think would be surprising which is yours
no
uh
you may just a second thank you
um I think the most
I think the most surprising thing might
be
um
what lies behind the dynamic of the
relationship
what what lies behind
the dynamic of the practices
and that is um
you know Angel Blue
puts herself in a position of great
vulnerability
and that's an expression of tremendous
Trust
I accept that
and in those times I'm absolutely
responsible for her well-being
physically
and emotionally
and I'm absolutely responsible for
maintaining that trust
and that
that giving of herself
at those times to me
and my accepting of that responsibility
and the mutual
care and and
acceptance and love that's
that happens in those times
and that's that's what lies at the heart
of the relationship at the heart of the
power dynamic
that the heart
of the practices
oh thank you
um I was going to say I think a lot of
people are surprised because when they
get to meet us they're surprised
um as to how funny we are and how uh
we're very playful I know we don't look
like it but we're very playful we're
very funny and I just like to have fun
and I would say even I would say
wholesome you know like we do a lot of
people something like the zoo and
um you know all these cute cutesy things
so I think people would be surprised to
find that out and I think those answers
were a perfect example of uh sort of
what each of us brings I was much more
serious
and Angel Blue was much more joyous
what what things would you like to do
together that you have not yet done in
your relationship
are there things that you see in the
future that uh
you'd like to do
more travel more work
and we have some work projects together
so
uh
I'm looking forward to more of that
yes we um we have plants creative plants
to do together and
um
I think that's something that we're both
looking forward to is just working
together more because we make a pretty
good team so we want to do more of that
in the future could you ever see being
the slave of any other man other than
Berlin No I it's funny you mentioned
that because I was I was telling him
last night that
um I actually started crying because I
said
I can't imagine you not being in my life
I can't imagine it it I just feel I
really hope that we go together
I really do because that that empty
space I feel nobody can feel that nobody
can feel that thing that that person
brings to you
so yeah I that's been on my mind that
you know in the future whenever it's our
time to go whoever goes first who knows
but I sure do wish that we'll go
together
the fact that Berlin is so much older
he's like like is it 30 years
is that a concern of yours
in the future he looks healthy as a
horse now but but I am hopefully you'll
live to be 150 but yes yes but there's a
chance that he might go before you
you know it is a concern and I always
tell him you never know I almost died
um quite a few times quite a few times
so you never know you never know but it
definitely I worry about him a lot a lot
I'm always constantly
checking up like are you okay or you
know
um just even this weekend we had a
little incident and you know and a
previous incident I actually saved his
life so that's true I had a medical
email the the only major surgery of my
life and it was a medical emergency
and
uh if she hadn't called the ambulance I
don't know what would have happened
yes so that is um it does weigh on me
sometimes it does because I really
I feel like we met
um
even though we've been together 30 000
years but in this life I feel that we
met late in the game
but it's okay because it was well worth
it we were meant to meet
and we'll meet again no matter what
happens and we'll just keep
we'll just keep being together
so that
um that calms me
and as you say I am healthy as a horse
and
that in itself is good I come from good
genes and
and who knows what awaits in the near
medical future
you know come up with something that
helps us extend our lives even more
that's correct
what is your typical week look like who
does the cooking for example
I do you do I do I do the cooking the
cleaning the laundry uh the errands who
pays the bills
who pays them actually pays them who
actually writes the check and puts it
yeah
but who pays for it she's the CFO yes I
understand you you probably bring home
the bacon but she might be the one that
pays the bills she's she's
not
very good at not spending money
yes really she excels at not spending
money
yes I've helped him that's refreshing
yes you would think this might be a
sugar sugar baby sugar daddy
relationship
not at all at all actually our biggest
um issue in our relationship has been
that he overspends and I understand but
it's to the point where he has told me
don't take away my happiness by being so
Frugal like don't don't take that away
but my background it's so hard for me
because my background I'm constantly
worried I'm constantly do you come from
not necessarily the most wealthy family
I come from
government cheese I come from welfare
food stamps
so I it's so embedded in me that fear
the fear of
um and you know I had my time on the
streets so we have completely different
backgrounds and he the way that he would
though I felt like he was just throwing
money away and I I couldn't I couldn't
it was
I don't know it was insane to me so now
uh that's what that's why she's in
charge of
she's the CFO yeah he gave me that job
as your accountant right there you go
yeah he gave me that job
and uh I can even remember early on
I was I was in the middle of
getting her a gift and I I texted her
something about it and her response was
do you really think that's necessary
this
yeah it was uh I don't need all that it
was nice it was it was different
it almost appears as an outsider that it
looks like maybe Berlin you found
a diamond in the rough and you polished
her up and fixed her up and gave her a
better life more opportunity
is is that
inaccurate or is that kind of what
happened
I'd say that that is uh
that I'd say that's
largely accurate I mean
I provided her with patience and care
enough
and guidance and boundaries enough
and stuck with it long enough
for who she was yeah no I think there's
something appealing and exciting for a
man to like in your position to find
somebody who could you benefit from your
that's true your guidance all the things
that you provide that's true that is and
watch her turn into who she could be
I I saw who she was
I saw
the good in me so the good in her
the uh the the
childhoods that you guys came from
Berlin I don't know much about your
childhood what
tell me about you know you came from
a more well-to-do family I came from uh
much more well to do than her family was
my family had its own
um
issues
including issues with violence
um
uh
and it took me a long time
to
understand
and understand
where that came from understand the
historic basis for it and to
um
to really appreciate
the good
that that
I was so fortunate to have
in the household in which I grew up
I mean
no matter what I can like my parents
certainly loved me
are you
similar to your father
yes
I wasn't always
but I definitely am yeah if I find we
all turn into our parents
pardon we all turn into our parents
whether we like it or not
uh
perhaps I can only speak for myself and
I can definitely say I am very similar
to my father in many ways and
um
and
I do like it I embrace it uh
you said whether we like it or not my
vote is in my case for my experience I
like it
dear friends raise an eyebrow sometimes
to your
relationship
our friends generally don't know about
our our private relationship quite
frankly
I wouldn't be here for this interview
but for the fact that I'm hoping our
experience might be of some service to
some others
yes please I just wanted to add that all
of our friends know we don't have any
friends that are in the BDSM Community
or anything with fetishes all of our
friends are just they're vanilla and we
actually we prefer that
we prefer just having
the typical life
but then when we have our private time
then
we just you know do our extreme stuff
but that's just in our private and it
makes it more fun too because it you're
happy it's almost like having a double
life in a way because you're out doing
you know PTA and you're doing sleepovers
and parties and church and work and all
these
you know family time amazing things but
then when we have alone time it we just
go extreme and intense and that makes it
even more exciting it's your little
secret yeah that only you should you two
share yes and and it balances things out
too there's a balance
I see so many relationships that appear
like they've they've kind of gotten
stale
and the conversations that the couple is
having are the same conversations
they've had for the last seven years
and it just like I don't know what the
remedy is for that other than
cheating or having some you know
splitting up or something whereas you
guys probably keep it very alive and
interesting yes yes we do yes very we
when we come together and we have that
alone time we make the most of it
because we don't always have that in a
long time so we there's a lot of ritual
involved there's a lot of props it'd be
a performance
a lot of performance because my dear my
dear M uh he requires
um dress up he requires makeup and I'm a
tomboy I was never into any of this
dressing up until we met so he requires
the whole
the whole enchilada and more then we
have uh
there's things like slave positions uh
just things that we get into and we
because we are religious we add a
religious aspect to to our alone time
and it makes it it intensifies it
so it's very almost sacrilegious would
you say no no I wouldn't wait isn't
wait is that am I using the right word
am I using them I don't know I was
trying to say sacred ah then you use it
oh the opposite of oh sorry about that
guys it
are coming together and it's more it
feels more about the souls I always
wanted to find a man that would go there
with me that would take that step and I
when I met him a few months after I met
him I asked him if he would take the
step of
um
leave the details oh okay sorry
that's all right go ahead and and he did
and well at first he didn't at first he
turned me down and he said well I'm not
ready to do that with you because that's
an eternal it was going to be for
eternity and he said I'm not ready and I
was crushed I was so heartbroken but
fast forward to three months later after
he went to New Orleans and all these
things and he said I'm ready to and we
we did on several continents we took
that we made a commitment to one another
yes
special one
spiritual one
is there any advice you guys can give
I'm not saying you and everyone should
adopt your type of relationship but I'm
sure there's things you have learned
about the Dynamics of of this kind of
relationship that would apply to all
relationships to keep them alive keep
them interesting keep them
growing
respect communication honesty
beautiful and may I add also
um
mystery business don't lose that uh that
playfulness don't lose that because that
you the the inner child is so important
and when it comes out boy does it come
out
agreed
all right Berlin and Angel Blue thank
you so much for coming back and thank
you giving us a little more information
about your very interesting lives
you guys are great thank you so much
and uh thank you for having us we
appreciate the opportunity to uh to do
this and uh
if I might say
good work on the interview Mark oh thank
you very much
all right you guys thank you very much